- Sur le long chemin
de la réconciliation,
une nomination symbolique :
la Couronne britannique au
Canada sera, pour la première
fois, représentée
par une Autochtone.
- I spent my adolescence
in Nunavik.
- Elle s'appelle Mary Simon
ou Ningiukadluk, dans sa langue
maternelle. Elle est née dans
le Grand Nord québécois.
Elle est honorée et
touchée face à ses nouvelles
responsabilités, et plusieurs
femmes autochtones voient
sa nomination comme
une victoire.
MICHÈLE AUDETTE
- Ma première réaction, c'est...
un petit "ouak", là, une fierté.
NANCY ETOK, amie et
collègue de Mary Simon
- J'ai crié, j'ai... j'étais...
Ah! C'était incroyable!
- Diplomate de carrière,
Mary Simon a été représentante
inuite lors du rapatriement
de la Constitution, déléguée du
Canada au Conseil de l'Arctique
et ambassadrice au Danemark.
Alors que le pays est confronté
à la découverte de tombes
anonymes d'enfants près des
pensionnats pour autochtones,
la nomination de Mary Simon
est plus que symbolique,
affirme le premier ministre.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- Je pense que c'est quelqu'un
qui va amener une perspective,
un poids, des capacités
importantes pour le pays,
en ce moment, de réflexion
et de croissance.
- Dans ce contexte,
comment une Autochtone
peut accepter d'être le chef
d'État du pays que certains
considèrent comme l'oppresseur?
Mary Simon n'y voit pas
de contradiction.
- I don't see a conflict.
LYNNE GROULX, Association des
femmes autochtones du Canada
- Même si, voilà, c'est un poste
qui est vraiment encore
supérieur dans un système
qui est encore de gouvernance
coloniale, mais par contre,
on doit participer à la société.
- Puis ,il y a la question
de la langue. La nouvelle
gouverneure générale pourra
distribuer les honneurs
en inuktitut et en anglais,
mais elle ne parle pas
le français, parce qu'il était
interdit de le parler à l'école
fédérale pour Autochtones
qu'elle fréquentait
dans les années 50.
- Ça va accrocher
la communauté francophone
à travers le Canada. Ça va
accrocher, oui, certainement.
Moi, c'est sûr que j'aurais
beaucoup aimé qu'elle parle
francais.
- La principale intéressée
promet de l'apprendre.
- Je prends très au sérieux
mon rôle de défenseur de
la diversité culturelle
et linguistique.
- L'installation de
la 30e gouverneure générale
du Canada aura lieu bientôt;
la date reste à déterminer.
C'est à elle que Justin Trudeau
devra s'adresser s'il veut
déclencher des élections
hâtives. Mais le premier
ministre assure que
les deux n'ont pas
encore abordé la question.
Ici Christian N